Ron Paul would probably take about 17 to
18 percent of the national vote hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with reason TV today
we're talking with Emily Ekins director
of polling at Reason Foundation we've
got our latest edition of the reason
roop foundation pole coming out this was
questions asked of Americans in
mid-march let's talk about politics
what's the Republican Party nomination
process shaping up like we found that
Mitt Romney is pulling ahead with
thirty-nine percent among Republican and
independent leanin Republican voters
with Rick Santorum of trailing at
twenty-six percent Ron Paul is third
with n gingrich's fourth yep in general
election matchups you say that Romney or
the poll results show that Romney is a
better chance of beating Obama that Rick
Santorum around Paul but Obama beats all
of them could you talk a little bit
about that so according to our poll
Obama still pulls ahead by about three
to five percentage points ahead of
Romney antsy and Santorum and Paul
however romney does better than Santorum
and Paul what's the spread between
Romney and Obama at this point well
neither of them get fifty percent but as
this poll reveals Obama still pulls
ahead by about three to five percentage
points ahead of Romney and about five to
seven percentage points ahead of Rick
Santorum and Ron Paul what do the pole
find if Ron Paul runs as an independent
candidate Ron Paul would probably take
about 17 to 18 percent of the national
vote and he would take votes from both
President Obama and the Republican
nominee both Romney and Santorum if they
were the GOP nominee he would take votes
from both however he would take a few
percentage points more from the
Republican
candidate Iran is in the news because of
possible building of nuclear facilities
for bombs and things like that we're
coming out of you know a decade of wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan how are
Americans looking at a military
intervention in Iran we find about fifty
percent of Americans it would favor
military intervention in Iran if experts
believe that it were close to being able
to produce a nuclear weapon however when
we asked if attacking Iran would lead to
a war with Iran that's similar in length
and costs to the war in Iraq then
opposition shoots up to fifty six
percent Americans don't want another war
like that and this seems to be one of
the things that the reason root poll is
doing that is distinct right which is
not simply asking how do you feel about
something but how do you feel with a
particular price tag attached correct
what is what's the benefit of doing that
from a polling perspective because we
live in a world of trade-offs we live in
a world with benefits and costs and so
if we were to just ask you know would
you like this particular policy program
or this benefit most people say yes but
it costs money or it has trade-offs
opportunity costs and so for a policy to
work we have to know if the public is
willing to accept the costs to obtain
the benefit speaking about costs and
benefits taxes big in the news the Paul
Ryan GOP plan is talking about an
overhaul of the tax code Obama has made
gestures sorts changing tax rates what
are we finding about our Americans ready
to contemplate changing the federal tax
code our poll results suggest that is
the case we asked Americans to use one
word to describe how they feel about
filing their taxes and the word that
kept coming up kept coming up was
complicated and anxiety and so we asked
about favorability towards a flat tax
that would eliminate all federal
deductions and in fact fully fifty
percent of americans said they would
favor a flat tax and so then we followed
up and asked well if we were to have a
flat tax
we're all Americans pay the same rate
about what percentage of income should
that be so we averaged up those
responses and it's about fourteen
percent I want to thank Emily Ekins
polling director of Reason Foundation
and author of the reason roof Pole which
comes out quarterly a national poll that
asks Americans about everything that's
important to them and what it costs
Emily thanks for speaking with us